now if you have been honest with you you
think you'd been able to be one of those
women who can let their man have another
woman um no I don't think so
I mean not not this particular person
anybody but her any anybody behind y'all
know like a friend um it's just she was
a problem one of the problems so at the
end of the day I don't think I would
have been able to share you know I don't
think I would have been able to share
but I probably would have tried really I
definitely would have tried because I
mean when you love someone you would do
anything for them
anything I would have done anything
[Music]
[Music]
she was taught to you speaking from the
heart
yes mary j blige lutely yeah what you
think what do you think of Ramadan
Mubarak we're all about MOBOTIX - yeah a
lot of [ __ ] Sheikh Shadid Mohammed and
you've been with us before I'm happy
that you're back again I'm glad to be
back
how's life been how's everything been
kind of life how's it how's it going I
mean it's exactly the way that Allah
wanted it to be absolutely yeah you know
what what can we do yeah
relationships are a very important part
of the Dean right half a year denial of
your religion yeah and none of them are
breaking up out of them you know people
what do you think of what she was saying
she was willing to do anything right for
her man right yes she said that she
would even have considered allowing her
husband to have another woman just to
keep you know just to maintain what they
had and that's that's the power of love
and that's one of the things that I
talked about in my book you know the
resolution of love that love cannot be
compartmentalized you can't say that
this is the you know we try to say that
this is the way love is supposed to
operate you know and love doesn't
function according to anybody's
frequency it functions on its own
frequency you know and mm-hmm it's an
emotion just like any other emotion and
emotions are not supposed to make sense
I think it was Shakespeare who said you
know you know Vayne is the person who
believes that emotions are supposed to
make sense they're not supposed to make
sense their emotions raw pure emotions
unfiltered and that came out in her
comment when she said I would be willing
to allow my husband to be with another
woman just to keep what I have because
when you invest in something to see the
thing about love is you know I was
having a discussion you know last week
with a group of young kids and one of
the questions that I asked is is a love
a weakness his love a weakness
and so most of the kids around the table
said no it's in its what makes you
strong and you know and I'm thinking
that maybe they didn't necessarily
understand the context of the question
but love is the greatest weakness
it's our kryptonite as human beings
because love requires you to let your
walls down and let a person see you for
who exactly who you are and that's scary
that's scary and a lot of people would
much rather keep the wall up paint a
facade and then let you fall in love
with the facade so you never actually
get to know who the person really is
because they are free to let those walls
now because it's it's the unknown is
this person once they see me for who I
really am are they really going to love
me or are they going to just you know
because there's nothing more shattering
to the human spirit then for you to let
your guard down let a person see you for
who you are and then for them to decide
no I don't you know I'm sorry I don't
want to love you you know how does the
person pick themselves up after
something like that so it's it's scary
so it is love is the greatest weakness
because it requires vulnerability and
people don't want to be vulnerable so
they'd much rather be surface they much
lather you fall in love with the fluff
of who they are and and some people are
okay with that how do you distinguish
between love and just lust someone
thinks they're really in love but really
is just an attraction they just have
this how do you differentiate between a
to lust and love well I think lust is a
result of not understanding love anybody
who is in lust is because they don't
understand love because why would you is
almost like a losses no karana tests
deputy new landlady who had an ability
who okay why would you opt for something
that is less than for something that is
greater than you know love is greater
than less but the only reason that you
would opt for lust is because you don't
understand love you know so you know I
you know I think lust is an immaturity
it's a person who just is in tune with
the physical aspect of a relationship
she's cute he's cute the sex is great
you understand what I'm saying those are
the
aspects of relationships love is where
you can come into this person space and
let your guard completely down and let
them love you the way that they feel
most comfortable loving you and you're
totally okay with that and there's
nothing greater than that Oprah Winfrey
said that during the time that she had
her show The Oprah Winfrey Show which
ran from the mid 80s all the way up
until the early 90s and she said during
the course of her show she interviewed
over 30,000 people she said and one
thing that all of those people had in
common one thing that they all had in
common was all of them were looking for
validation that's all anyone ever wants
is to be valid to know that they matter
to know that you know someone else sees
their worth that's all they want and a
person who is obviously in lust will
never get that because less is there's
barriers to lust that will not allow you
to go any further than that you don't go
any further than the physical aspect of
the relationship and it's
objectification because once you get the
lust once you get you satisfy that lusts
you're basically done with the person
and then it's off to the next person and
this is what is happening in many
communities including the Islamic
community where relationships where
marriages have now become business deals
you know you pay my rent you take care
of your and then quid pro quo
you know you do for me and then I'll do
for you and this is not love love as she
said as mary j blige said that I would
have been willing to allow my husband to
have a relationship with another woman
to keep my marriage that's love that's
love because love doesn't function on a
quid pro quo if you give me love then
I'll give you love you love regardless
in spite of the fact that the person
doesn't love you but ultimately the one
who's in control of the heart the
creator the having the earth is is is
love just the natural consequences of
coming together or at least if you hold
the boundaries set by the Creator
eventually that love will come but
should there can there be a functioning
marriage even if every everybody agrees
to the terms to how it should be and
they function
Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish
Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish
Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish
Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish Anish
Anish Kapoor Sasha aagha Atul Sabharwal
romance Mickey virus Manish Paul Varun
Badola Manish Choudhary Saurabh Varma
Neumann
I wonder what the results look at the
results results results the result of
the little little mechanical engineering
another important result results results
results results results results
that was a'that at at at the varsity the
the minutiae the manure the the manoomin
emoney manure manure manure
[Music]
he's acquired by submission to the
little map with the world the only
classroom adapt
[Music]
welcome back to the Dean show or with my
old friend shake Shadid Muhammad and
before we went to break tomba alpha-male
and it would would Adam Lohnes
I for the people I don't know there was
a lot of media he's been on many of the
popular talk shows gotta say you just
look like the cat that's got the cream
sitting there with you ladies I think
that's a trouble Adam isn't it there's
always that kind of notion of all he's
having his cake and eating it all here
happy lucky Jack sent us why it's deeper
than that for you yeah I think you know
I get that a lot news articles all
because he has two girlfriends that he
lives with and they share a king-size
bed
the throuple share a king-size bed and
take turns in it to have romantic date
night together right and it's just
ironic that he's been called the
luckiest man kind of society not
everybody but it's kind of something
that hasn't been shamed to look down
upon and he's probably he's been propped
up like you know this is a good thing
you know what I mean by a lot of people
it's not now it's on the other side it
just kind of a double standard if a man
goes and was to because he's got
girlfriends right and they're doing
things that are inappropriate you know
according to God and if this man would
have took them as his wives and maybe
they had a king size bed just for the
two and he had separate houses and he
took care of them individually right he
did the the way that the COS legislation
responsible way the responsible ways
kind of looked down upon why is that
well I just think that that's this a
microcosm of where our society is I mean
you know not to get political but we
have a president that tweets threats to
other people and I mean this is socially
acceptable so I just think that you know
this is a microcosm of where our society
is and the type of the social standards
that have been lowered and now have
become the new norm
you know and the prophet sallahu was
some you know he prophesized that times
like this would come he called it's a no
a turkey that you know years of
deception where the believer the the the
person who's truthful will be considered
untruthful and the person as you know
untruthful will be considered truthful
and a person as trustworthy will be
considered untrustworthy and you know so
basically things that were normally
acceptable will be replaced with a new
norm and so today we're a man such as a
Muslim who's you know abiding by the
religion of Islam can marry more than
one woman provide for them equally you
know financially emotionally you know
religiously provide for these women on
the equal basis and be responsible with
that and having children from them and
you know in raising those children as
his own this is something that is
frowned upon and then you take the same
in the same concept and just remove all
of the religious rules and regulations
and just say a man just takes two
girlfriends and you know any goals and
he gets both from them pregnant at the
same time and he's living with them in
the same home you know no respect for
the human boundaries of you know people
needing their own space the
responsibility of you know years ago a
man having a child with a woman that he
wasn't married to would have been
considered illegitimate and a crime a
crime action Houser delivers a crime
absolutely it was a crime right here in
American society it was actually a crime
and you know those children would have
been considered illegitimate and today
you know we prop people up like this and
we you know we sing their praises today
and it almost seems like anything that
is not tied or connected to religion is
acceptable it doesn't matter how absurd
doesn't matter how weird or how socially
abnormal it is as long as it's not
connected to any religion is socially
acceptable anytime something is
connected to a religion based upon
divine laws and rules and regulations is
frowned upon this unaccepted yeah even
in the in the community you'll see where
they talked about this the
and is considered you know scumbag the
woman is like stupid for allowing this
right right this is kind of like
opposite but then here you go Adam he's
like the luckiest man alive people are
like man he's our hero and some women
are even considering it now even in the
even in the Islamic community you know
part of the reason why polygyny is not
able to you know take its its rightful
place in our religion is because of
Muslims who are you know who you know
have allowed the societal norms of where
we live to define to define what is
acceptable even in our religion so you
have Muslim women who would think about
or consider marrying into a plural
marriage situation and you might she
might be stigmatized and she might be
frowned upon and looked at as stupid or
you know less of less intelligent for
doing so you know you have women that
will say well you're smart you're
beautiful you're young why would you you
know marry into a situation like this
where you have non-muslims who now this
growing trend of a man being with
multiple women in a boyfriend-girlfriend
setting or you know in a context of
being a boyfriend and girlfriend and
they and they're actually trying to make
it work you know and it's almost you
know hypocritical to some degree and it
is a double standard why it seems like
in another aspect people again are
trying to tell women what to do
I mean this is like this is a mature
woman this is actually her right right
people always look at it from one angle
this is like the man but no this is a
blessing for women absolutely and I are
not doing my control for not being I'm
saving your of our own free will yeah
don't you don't need to rescue us we're
okay anyone needs saving actually and
they probably out and now you're trying
to impede on a woman's right and try and
tell her again what to do and what she
can right absolutely and any any woman
that is in polygyny at least in american
society anyway and they had tons of
muslim families at practice polygyny
even here in america any woman that is
in that situation is in that situation
because she chose she chose to marry
into a situation like that there's a
quote that I bring at the beginning of
my book did her religion forced her to
do that no that is not Islam say look
that you have to do this not at all okay
there's a quote that mentioned in the
beginning of my book by Kim George and
it says behind every happy couple lies
to people who have fought hard to
overcome all obstacles and interferences
to be that way why because it's because
that's what they wanted they chose to be
that way so when you find two people two
women or three women in a situation
where they are married to one man that
is their choice they chose to find
happiness they chose to find love in a
non-conventional a non-traditional
relationship they chose to find love
that way why is it that we will make
excuses for people who you know for
same-sex relationships will make every
excuse in the world they were born that
way you know no one can judge them no
one can determine where they find love
but then when we try to find out follow
a divine law divine law and this is not
just in Islam religion is just not
allowed in Islam but also in
Christianity offered as well as in
Judaism these are divine laws that have
allowed this practice for generations
and you know we would condemn that but
then we would make excuses for something
that no divine law would you know would
condone our people like an uproar
politicians are they like you know
really going after deer a he's got a
show I heard you're telling me DeRay
Davis I have the two live-in girlfriends
yes I do
okay how do you make that work they work
with each other they're comfortable are
they comfortable you make it work by
paying the bills now let's be real you
still have the two girlfriends for the
rest of my life more than that getting
day off today live with yourself all my
other girlfriends by at least by saying
is just to I will say this night to at
the top before than everything I've been
over there adamant about sad shakes I
got seven lives yeah yes it's pretty
popular show yes yeah absolutely are
people is again is is are they trying to
ban I mean I they trying to come after
him are people not all testing it's
become the new norm because it's not
connected to any religion so if a hit
show
yes so means that music say it except is
socially acceptable absolute
and I believe that if he was to come out
tomorrow and say that he's a Muslim and
he's going to marry both of these women
and do it the Islamic way they were shut
the show off he would be the worst not
the luckiest guy in the world he would
be the worst man in the world so as long
as they're your girlfriend it's okay go
along but it put them in the back put
him in the trunk put them into you ha as
many as you want right but as soon as
you marry these women intentionally I
mean you think about I hate to go there
but I mean you think about somebody like
Hugh Hefner who has a Playboy Mansion
where he has all of these women living
in this mansion many of whom he sleeps
with never condemned for that but a man
who marries more than one woman
responsible he has children with them
those children bear his name those
children will inherit from him he's
condemned mm-hmm you know this is the
society that we have do you think people
because a lot of times this might get
associated with something evil people
have seen what's been projected on the
media many of these cults Mormon
religion you know people having like all
these underage girls no limit to um
they're doing all sorts of scandalous
things so now people attribute that
other times when people misuse and abuse
religion and some of the beautiful
things I've been sanctioned by the
creator now people have a really bad
taste in their mouths do you think this
might kind of have something to do with
it
yeah I think it has a lot to do with it
people tend to say well if it's if it's
if it's an institution if it's a
relationship that is governed by
religion then we tend to think that the
woman was forced into that situation the
religion forces that opponent or super
imposes that on the woman and we never
stop to think that in Islam nothing is
super imposed on you you have a choice
in everything in this religion this is
the beauty of the religion you know
Allah says in many verses in the Quran
for mention a fellow men women Shia
fanuc for whoever wishes to you know
believe they let him believe and whoever
wishes to disbelieve then let him
disbelieve you know their verses in the
Quran where Allah says that you know
feminists today yesterday Lynn FC woman
won laughs in the mail with Lou Ali her
that whoever finds guidance finds
guidance for the benefit of his own soul
and
whoever chooses to find misguidance then
he does so to the detriment of his own
soul you have a choice in everything in
our religion you have a choice in
everything but people usually associate
religion with you know imposition you
know this is imposed on you per the
religion and so therefore you don't have
a brain you know this is what things are
said about Muslim women they don't have
a brain they don't think for themselves
their husbands make all of their
decisions for them you know not just
with Islam I'm sure Christian women of
the same caliber you don't run into the
same stigmas the same you know you know
the the same you know same things but
the fact of the matter is that the
religion doesn't superimpose that any
woman who is in a monogamous
relationship is in a monogamous
relationship because she chose to and
you know any woman that is married
against her will in Islam whether
monogamy and more so in polygyny then
the marriage is invalid no forced
marriage and so there is no forty can't
force a woman to gain which means that a
woman actually does have a brain yeah
woman can actually choose for herself as
a matter of fact prophet muhammad
sallallahu wasallam he said you know as
the thing abou I have to be NFSA
manually that the woman who was a matron
the woman who has been married
previously she has more right to decide
who she wants to marry than her own
father why because a woman who has
experienced marriage previously she now
knows because marriages want to bring
out things about yourself you're going
to learn a lot about yourself in this
institution of marriage and even once
that marriage dissolves and you move on
you have learned so much more about
yourself and you know you're able to
distinguish now your needs from your
one's going into a marriage from the
very beginning as a virgin whether male
or female we complete our needs with our
ones we don't know the difference
between what we need and what we want
hence the fact we make a lot of mistakes
in the marriage but once you leave that
marriage you exit that marriage you have
a clear finite understanding of your
needs and your ones and therefore a
woman has more right to decide who she
wants to marry then her wali
then our own guardian you know yeah
we're going to we're going to take a
break
wonderful topic was out of time I love
and we're talking about polygyny we
jumped into it can you separate the two
we have so much more to talk about I
want to ask you that how wisest have to
come up if he loves me why'd you have to
you know what I have to share is man
program is man program like this what's
all this about why is he have to even
why just have to even have to be a
discussion with breath with Mort answer
these very important questions don't go
anywhere let us follow in the footsteps
of the greatest men who ever walked this
earth the messenger that God Almighty
sent like Abraham Moses Jesus and
Mohammed peace be upon them all who all
called people to worship the Creator
alone and not this creation take a
moment now fulfill one of those
qualities and Nets of giving towards the
dollar-something
all these great Giants did and call
people to do help us reach our yearly
goal from it out help be part of sharing
the truth support the details
[Music]
you
back here on the Dean show so why do we
again some people might say why are you
even taught is Ramadan you know why are
you guys talking about this we got
serious issues going on and not only are
you the author of the book what's the
book called the revolution of the rebel
olive love so we start talking about
love now we're talking about this
extending the family right can you
separate it I move the word to use
extending the family yeah so someone
says why are you guys even discussing
this if he loves me then he wouldn't be
even bringing this up why why the issue
now well look some goes back to
something that you said before we went
to the break and that is a is man wire
genetically to be with just one woman or
is this something that you know is just
part of his biological makeup that he
has to be with more than one woman there
was a study called the the Coolidge
effect and this is actually chapter one
in my book the Coolidge effect and this
is a phenomenon where researchers found
that when a man is with one woman for a
substantial amount of time he goes
through what is called a post
ejaculatory refractory period which is
which means basically that he gets tired
of being with the same woman for a
substantial amount of time but when a
new woman is introduced into the
relationship then it kind of rekindles
he wakes up again he wakes up again
absolutely and they did the study with
mice they did it with other animals and
this is another science is the science
so basically is saying that men are not
genetically wired to be with one woman
for the duration of his life
I mean case closed so well how are you
going to beat up on America so that's
not to say that some men are not content
with one woman and they are some men are
but those men that are content with one
women with one woman those men are the
exception to the rule not the rule
evidence by the many document
well documented as well as those had
that have not been documented instances
of men that are having extramarital
relationships with women that they're
not married to you know polygyny was
actually the the standard of marriage
before the dawn of the roman catholic
church believe it or not historically
anthropologists have studied you know
ancient societies and have found that
polygamy was the actual practice of
marriage that a man and of course there
was no limit because it wasn't actually
a divine law this was just something
that and I mean this is something
documented even with many of the
prophets prophesy lay men had more than
one wife Prophet Ibrahim by the SNM we
we have you know um practices
celebratory practices in our religion
that commemorates you know one of you
Brahimi wives and another one that
commemorates another wife you know he
had one wife adjure daddy left him in
mecca with his son Ismael and he had
another wife Sarah that he left in
Palestine but the bible does the Bible
talk about him having three wives I'm
not sure I'm not sure how many wives but
they're well documented
you know instances in the Bible where
men had more than Prophet David prophet
dude these are so the greatest men to
walk to earth they had exam absolutely
they had they had big families you know
there's a incident incident where
prophet Sulayman who had ninety-nine
wives and he said in a hadith the
Prophet Salah Jerusalem said that he
said I'm going to go to all of my wives
and one night and each one of them is
going to deliver a male child that will
fight in the cause of Allah but he
didn't say in sha Allah so which means
if God wills right and so he went to all
of his wives and none of them gave birth
to a child except one and the child came
out you know deformed it was only half
of a child you know and the point that
I'm making is that we see all of these
stories documented you know stories
divine stories that are you know
documenting you know these men these
great men that we look up to that we
praise that we try to emulate you know
and incorporate their behaviors in our
day to day character
and yet when we try to emulate that
particular aspect of their lives then
it's frowned upon and shunned and so to
answer your question why are we actually
having this discussion why if a man
loves a woman the why does he need
another woman can a man love more than
one woman because when you say if he
loves her why does he need another woman
so basically you're you're saying that
his love should be restricted to her if
he loves her then he should not want
another woman so then basically here we
go again
trying to put love in a box can a man
love more than one woman absolutely but
he cannot love them equally the same we
don't love our children equally the same
there's no human being that can say you
have ten children you love each and
every one of your children the exact
same way you don't there's always that
one child that your heart you know just
inclines towards you know for whatever
reason you know you always have this one
child that has a special need that maybe
the other children don't have or another
child that is very vulnerable and naive
and you have to cater to that child more
than the other does that mean that
there's a baseline love that you have
for all of your children yes there's a
baseline love that you have for all of
your children but is there a particular
child that your heart just you know
inclines towards absolutely absolutely
we all say if we grew up in big families
I don't know about you I grew up in a
you know I have three sisters and we
always say that this particular child is
my mom's favorite you're the favorite
this is the argument among siblings who
is the favorite right this was the
argument amongst prophet youssef right
what did the brothers the Prophet used
to say that you know that Yusef is you
know is more beloved to prophet yaqoob
than we are well not know Russa and we
are a bigger group because prophet
yaqoob himself had more than one wife
right so Yusef and Benny Amin was from
one wife and the other brothers were
from another wife and so the confusion
or the the the disgruntlement was
because the group the larger group of
brothers thought that prophet yaqoob
love use of and Binyamin more than he
loved him
so this happens even among siblings you
know that who's the most favorite so
this shows that the parents and no
matter how much you as a parent try to
love your children equally children they
pick up on these things just as if you
have multiple wives they're going to
pick up on that as well they're going to
see that you know this particular wife
you let her get away with certain things
and this particular wife you you know
cater to her in a certain way and that's
just human that's just who we are as
human beings but can a man love more
than one woman yes
can he love them equally the same no
love should be as I've heard multiplied
not divided
multiplied not that one no no I have now
yeah I want to make it a comparison here
to kind of trends changing and where do
we want to be and maybe you can see
where I'm going with and kind of
correlate this to our discussion you
know when you look at some one of the
signals that we have and again this goes
back to the great men they all used to
have the beard right right and if you
even look at now science today it's
showing that it helps to prevent cancer
with the UV rays coming in so I just get
amazed with the deep that we don't
obviously do it because of that but even
in these things there's great wisdom
right of the divine right so this
article talks about in terms of legit
study we'll have it up where it is
cancer preventing for preventing the
rays coming and hitting your the UV rays
your skin also many of the pollens and
everything is trapped here for help
prevent asthma the list goes on but not
that you have so many athletes on so
many have you noticed everyone has a
beard nowadays not everyone but a
growing number of people it's become
like the new trend right right but we
were doing it before was trendy right
but now on the other side you have a lot
of you know people who you know because
of the culture right before years back
people were looking down upon you
because you had a beard you follow me
but now because it's fashionable people
are like growing acceptable some people
are just staying still behind my Rami
but now acquainting that to here we gave
some examples with DeRay Davis many
people might not know was me I didn't
you mentioned him mary j blige but adam
lines who
Minh Minh Minh Minh linear manure manure
Anu Malik didn't even eat manure manure
manure manure manure manure manure -
even even even even even even even even
even even eat
montgomeryville nissan montgomeryville
nissan your PA area nissan dealer
montgomeryville nissan your PA area
nissan dealer montgomeryville
everybody who comes in and knows all
[Music]
mineva
as even even even
wearing the hijab when you know whether
it's socially accepted or not we still
have an obligation to stick to our
values and our principles
absolutely what are some of the favorite
chapters in your book
I think the chapter can a man love more
than one woman I think that that's very
you know very interesting you know even
myself as I was writing the you know
book and you know documenting you know
some of my thoughts about the chapter um
you know it just opened up a whole you
know can of worms as it relates to the
concept of love I'm a convert to Islam
so much of what I saw coming into the
religion I didn't see you know um the
marriages Islamic marriages function the
way that I saw in Christianity and
that's not to say that Christian
marriages are more valid in Islamic
marriages that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that Islamic
marriages tend to function on a very
quid pro quo you know type of philosophy
you know as long as you're giving me my
rights
I'll give you your rights you know and I
you know grew up in a home where I've
seen my parents you know um you know
maybe not necessarily get along but
divorce was never on the table the
divorce was never you know it's just
like almost like we had that and it we
abuse it you know it's almost like Adam
in the tree if Allah had not told Adam
don't eat from this tree is it a wonder
whether Adam would have even wanted to
eat from the tree it's like when you
tell someone don't do something we
desire what we can't have so when the
law says don't pronounce divorce or the
religion says divorce is not the most
desirable thing it's like that's the
thing that we desire the most you know
so you're fine Islam Muslim marriages
many muscle marriages are just you know
they're on airplane mode they just Coast
and husband and wife function as
roommates you don't really see love you
don't really see compassion you don't
really see and I'm a marriage counselor
so I counseled a lot of couples and I
can tell you a lot of the couples that
come through my door sometimes I'm
baffled and I'm saying to myself how can
two people who live together in a
relationship governed by a religion that
puts love at
home of the relationship how could you
function with each other like this I'm
amazed love is the cornerstone of our
religion aside from marriage the prophet
sallahu essence allow umino after the
comb had to you hid Leah clay he may
your humble in EM see none of you truly
believes and so you love you love for
your brother which you love for yourself
one of the laws names is a low dude
the loving love is at the helm of our
religion so how is it that two people
who share a relationship together
governed by a religion that puts love at
the forefront of everything that we do
how how could they do the things that
they do to one another you follow me yes
I just don't understand it so it's
either we don't understand love or we do
but we just don't have a regard for it
we don't care for it you know and that's
another trend that is going on in our
society where relationships are just
business deals you know you you pay for
my rent you take care of me and then
I'll take care of you sexually our you
know make your food I'll do whatever I
need to do on my part but I'm not doing
it out of love
I'm doing it because you're doing for me
what I need you to do for me it's a quid
pro quo philosophy and that's not love
the prophets Elijah was some of them he
was standing with one of his companions
and a man walked by and a man said to
him you know a Messenger of Allah I love
that guy and the Prophet said what did
you go tell him he said no he said go
tell him why did he tell him to go tell
him because when you tell someone I love
you it changes everything
it changes the way that they feel about
themselves some people don't even love
themselves some people don't even know
that it is okay to love themselves some
people seek validation for them for
their own selves by loving other people
they out in the service of other people
looking for self validation people spend
their lives as passengers in a vehicle
to their own self-awareness you're a
passenger in your own journey to self
awareness you don't even know
you're asking other people permission to
love yourself you know and so telling
someone that you loved them and
sincerely meaning it it forces the
person to see you differently and it
forces them to see themselves
differently some people don't love
themselves you know the Prophet was with
one of his companions you know um and
this guy was a slave and he was freed
and you know much like the naree the the
narrative of many of the Companions who
came out of slavery and things like that
and he was in the marketplace selling
his stuff and the Prophet walked behind
him that he'd have been Haram he walked
behind him and he grabbed him joking
with him and so you know he tried to
turn and see who it was and when he
realized it was the Prophet he relaxed
and the Prophet said jokingly men you
steady Minli has alive who will buy the
slave for me he was joking and the
servant he's in the Shia he said you
know if you are referring to me or
Messenger of Allah let's head you do me
Kassadin you will find me worthless you
will finally worthless goods no one
would buy me and the prophet sallahu a
sudden said Bell enter inda llahi
garland he said no to Allah you are
priceless you're priceless to Allah you
in society may see you as worthless but
in the sight of Allah you are priceless
boost of confidence boost of confidence
but what I'm saying is this is how some
people see themselves they see
themselves as being worthless as being
nothing this could be based upon their
upbringing based upon you know society
is just kind of dealt them a raw deal
you know they had that
hand they was dealt a bad hand for
whatever reason but you know love helps
to change that perception so you know
it's important that we make sure that
our marriages are founded on love and
not founded or superficial you know um
you know endeavors like saving myself
from the Hellfire here that often in the
Islamic community I want to get married
to save myself from the Hellfire okay
but the person that you are marrying
might be marrying for reason other than
that they might be marrying because they
actually want to be in love they've
never been in love before they want to
be in a relationship where they want to
have someone cater to their emotional
needs they want to be in a relationship
where they have someone cater to see
them as a human being to care for them
the way
that they've always wanted to be careful
while your only concern is I'm married
now I don't have to worry about
committing fornication right or adultery
right so it's kind of objectification
that we objectify the institution of
marriage and this is one of the things
that I talk about you know in my book
the revolution of love you know and this
this is probably the most important
chapter to me and then I have a chapter
at the end of the book called the do's
and don'ts of polygyny you know I could
have put more in there but I put a few
in there do's and don'ts of polygyny
basically like a poop a blueprint you
know a lot of us as men this is the
first time that we've ever been in any
situation remotely close to you know
polygyny you know yeah probably those of
us who are converts to Islam or those of
us who you know we're not practicing
Islam you know prior to our conversion
or prior to our submission to Islam we
may have had multiple girlfriends and
maybe have juggled a few women here and
there but being married to multiple
women is nowhere near in comparison to
juggling mode because there there's no
really no responsibility there's no
accountability there's no one to hold
you accountable you can basically do you
there's no responsibility but in in
Islam in polygyny there's responsibility
and there is accountability if that
responsibility is not fulfilled the
prophecy logical sometimes said that any
man who has more than one wife from a
lady that is that whom that he inclines
towards one of them more than the other
that he will come on the day of judgment
was home at in and one of his size will
be leaning he will be it would be a
deformity a deformity in front of the
world in front of everyone standing
there waiting to be judged and you will
stand there with this deformity in front
of everyone and everyone will know why
you are deformed and that is because you
incline towards one life more than the
other and there are other divine
consequences in this life as well as in
the hereafter for those you know we will
embark on this journey of polygamy so
you know it's there is a responsibility
and with responsibility there is
accountability before we come to an end
is there any chapter helping people to
[Music]
Miguel Miguel Miguel Miguel Miguel
[Music]
Miguel Miguel Beermen stylist
manure manure manure manure manure
[Music]
manure manure global company minee
sososo huzzah huzzah so do de de de de
de de de de de vos EO o EO EO o EO
nomine domine Quo Vadis
called oxytocin exit exit exit Satine
point that I'm making is that you know
when there's personal investment when
there's emotional investment in
something when you try to separate that
from the person that does not go easy so
a lot of times brothers are you know you
know are like well just get over it's
just jealousy no it's beyond jealousy
and trust me it is beyond jealousy
this woman has invested her entire life
in you and what you guys have built that
is you know you have to be emotionally
savvy you have to be you know very smart
very wise and how you introduce it how
you go about it and even if is the most
perfect the most picture-perfect
situation it's still not going to
diminish the emotion the jealousy the
insecurity and everything that comes
about as a result of your decision and
sometimes women never recover from that
I know women I've counseled women who
were taking medication because their
husbands have taken other wives so you
know and these were provided not some of
the best situations that were done in
the most upright manner and but what I
am saying is that even if you take the
most picture-perfect situation and you
do it the right way it still does not
mean that the woman is not entitled to
her emotions and her feelings and her
you know insecurities and you know all
of those things that are going to come
about you know and this is why the
prophet sallahu sort of intervened when
Eileen wanted to take a second wife
Eileen was married to the prophets
youngest daughter Fatima Fatima at the
time when she married Eileen her mother
was deceased Khadija was deceased and
all of her older sisters were deceased
zainabou paya uncle tomb there were all
diseased so fatima was basically the
baby girl and on top of being the
youngest she had no other female support
she had no support system and so Ali
wanted to marry the daughter of Abu
jahil who became Muslim she converted to
Islam Jamila and he wanted to marry her
as a second wife and the Prophet said no
he went to Eileen and he said I am NOT
making something Haram that Allah made
halal and this is very important for
people to understand he's not
challenging the polygyny what he's doing
is his room
moving his daughter from that situation
he said I'm not making something harmed
and Allah made halau he said but the
daughter of Muhammad will not be united
in a marriage with the daughter of the
enemy of Muhammad and I was a daughter
of Abuja you know how would that look in
the community for the Prophet to allow
you know I leave his who's married to
his daughter to marry another woman who
her father was the you know the fit out
of our money you know and you understand
what I'm saying like it complicates it
even more not only that as the scholars
explained the reason why the Prophet
intervene was because faatima didn't
have a support system the Prophet and
all of his wives and his family and
everything that his responsibilities he
would not have been able to be there for
her emotionally the way that she would
need someone and and women in those
situations they need maternal comfort
they need a mother they need women to
comfort them through those emotions
because they share those emotions a man
we don't understand what they're going
through
so the prophet sallahu a sudden he
intervened and until Ali no and I li you
know against the situation he later on
you know before Fatima died he later on
married into polygamy and actually the
situation worked out best because Fatima
was very sick and the other wife
actually assisted in that process but at
that moment it was it wasn't a good time
you know so what I'm saying is that this
chapter you know first wife syndrome
just kind of gives us a more in-depth
look into what our women are going
through when we decide to go into this
and then there's a second life syndrome
and that is the woman that is coming in
the new woman coming in and all of these
pressures that are put on her from both
her family from society and even
marrying into a family of already made
family just think about a woman who
maybe she's never been married before
and then she's marrying into a
polygynous situation and already made
family this guy has this this woman this
wife they have maybe two or three
children and she's marrying into this
situation it can be daunting it can be
very scary you know and so what I'm
doing is I'm highlighting you know some
of the pressures some of the challenges
that women are who are second wives come
in sometimes they come into a situation
and they feel like they have to pity
the first wife and they have to you know
conform to her every command just to try
to make her feel more comfortable I mean
think about a woman marrying into an
already made family sometimes she comes
in feeling like a homewrecker because
that's the stigma the community sees her
as a homewrecker
like you're marrying into this guy's
family and you're going to destroy his
family you're home wrecker yeah you know
but you have over here as we talked
about earlier the guy Adam who had two
wives is not married to him as his
girlfriend they do a lot of things
that's not sanctioned by the crater
right if Adam would he would marry them
right maybe accept Islam right do it
right right via different stove be great
and he'd get rewarded for that right but
my point is that in part of the
interview it talks about him actually
getting jealous how them two are
actually getting a lot of getting along
and how about each other right that's
ironic right over here you got them like
supporting helping and right he's
getting jealous of that life but over
here we don't have that we don't we
don't have that you know and that that
has always puzzled me why do Muslim
women struggle so much with something
that is already a part of our our
religion and then you have non-muslims
who this is a new phenomenon for them
you know to actually come to the
forefront of society and and learn to
accept that and stand in that and be
accepting of that this is a very new
phenomenon for them and they seem like
they're totally okay with it and they
seem like they fare very well with it
very maturely I think one of the
theories that I have about that is that
with non-muslims their relationships are
a lot different they pretty much get to
know each other as they go along with
Muslims it's like you know I'm meeting
with her her father mother very formal
you know and then we get married and
then we kind of start our journey to
learning one another we as with
non-muslims they're kind of taking that
journey simultaneously so you know
they're learning one another they're
being intimate with one another as they
move along in their relationship where
as Muslims we don't have that luxury you
know we don't have that luxury so
working people get the book revolution
of love the revolution of love a man's
perspective on loving multiple women in
an entre
additional marriage I actually have a
gift for you that's for you thank you
very much thank you very much an
omission of love you can purchase the
book from my website www.jfn.co.jp/toho
on as well and you can purchase the book
on Amazon as well revolution of love
get your copy thank you very much and
any advice for the brothers and sisters
out there and closing a few last minute
we have at last Ramadan advice anything
that you want to give shout out I would
just say to be generous in Roma Bahn the
prophets of lighting with some of them I
see she said that you know the Prophet
was very generous it was a very generous
person but the peak of his generosity
was in the month of Ramadan when Jibril
would meet with him every night in
Ramadan and review the Quran and the
prophets generosity wasn't just
restricted to being generous with money
usually when we hear be generous we're
thinking in terms of money but the
prophets generosity it was all
encompassing of every single aspect of
his life he was generous with his come
you know with his compliments he didn't
have a problem complimenting people you
know he saw you know Abdullah he was
climbing in a tree and the Sahaba were
laughing at his little legs and the
Prophet said are you laughing at his
legs he said I swear by Allah his two
little legs will weigh more on the
scales on the day of judgment in front
of Allah than the mountain of all hood
you know he didn't have a problem very
you know learn how to be generous with
your compliments learn how to compliment
people compliment yourself you know tell
yourself it's okay to tell yourself you
look like it's okay to tell yourself
you're handsome it's okay to tell you so
you're beautiful there's nothing wrong
with that be generous with your
compliments he was generous with his
time right with his time sometimes we
you know I don't really have time
sometimes we function through text
messages which kind of takes the emotion
out hence the fact we have emojis which
is the substitute for human emotion so
we're using pictures now to substitute
for human emotion and it's not fair
because human interaction requires
emotion so be generous with your time
you know don't send the text pick up a
phone and call the person hey you know I
was thinking about you know how you
doing you know just to hear the person's
voice and that human interaction is
something that we're moving totally away
from totally right so be generous with
your time you know the process a lot
even some of them you know one of the
women came and said o Messenger of Allah
you you you know the men take up all of
your time set aside a day for us just
the women in the community to teach us
and the Prophet agreed to that and he
would teach the women just the women on
a day so be generous with your time be
generous with your compliments be
generous with your money be generous
with your relationship with Allah that
if you believe you have a good
relationship with Allah then use that
relationship to help other people get to
the point where you believe you are
don't use that as a means of looking
down on people you say well you know I'm
here religiously and you're not though
that you having that position is a
privilege so you should use that to help
bring other people up to the level that
you believe you are the Prophet used
this position with Allah to bring people
up right we say level up to bring them
up to another level and examples you
know one of his companions or a beer if
you know carbon s Lemmy you know he said
Toto be at one time ask me for whatever
you want and I'll give it to you I'm
Robby I said well you know it kind of
caught him off guard with the question
so he said well let me think about it
for a little bit and then I'll get back
to you and so he said I thought to
myself you know this dunya the life of
this world is transitory its quick
passing it makes no sense to ask him to
ask Allah for something from this world
and you know my provision is going to
come to me regardless so he said why not
ask him for something from the Hereafter
so when he met the Prophet again the
Prophet asked him would o be it send me
or a teak he said ask me and I'll give
you what you want
he said you know you are aware of my
position with Allah asked me for what
you want and I'll give it to you and he
said o Messenger of Allah I ask you from
your [ __ ] all I want is your
companionship engender and the Prophet
said that's all you want he said who
would that K and also that's all I want
I just want to be your companion and
gentleman you know and the Prophet
you know supplicated on his behalf so to
use your
with a LOF you believe that you have a
good relationship with Allah then use
your relationship with Allah to help
others not to look down on a mat to
frown on them not to make yourself look
like you're better than them you know so
this is what I would say be generous in
the month of Ramadan and a loss of
penalty animals best shake Shadid
Mohammed thank you very much again a
pleasure my pleasure seeing you again
shallow we'll have you back
inshallah inshallah chocolate a quite
alright
[Music]